ils sont quarante artistes sur scène à
nous présenter des numéros
époustouflants
ils débutent leur tournée française et
ils sont le 25 novembre à la ferme du
manet à montigny le bretonneux
voici le cirque de hong kong dans le
kiosque salto la compagnie a été fondée
en 1956 en fait c'est la troupe se
trouve à la province
un quiz dans une ville qui s'appelle
recueil c'est la ville capitale de la
province
le cirque ne viendront kong en effet
c'est un centre de création artistique
qui se trouve à rank qui produit chaque
année des productions de danse de
l'acrobatie de très haute qualité
en chine les enfants il est entre dans
les écoles acrobatique à l'âge de 7 ans
8 ans c'est à dire à la che normale pour
les écoles parce que c'est un système d
ça fait partie de ce système et collines
et de l'explication chinoise ce qui est
différent c'est ce sont les écoles
professionnelles donc pour un numéro ça
dépend ça dépend de la difficulté de
numéros aussi ça dépend de talent des
artistes
il ya dans le même numéro il ya des
artistes qui peuvent faire en un an mais
pour les autres ça peut faire deux trois
ans avant il ya tout un entraînement de
danse la chorégraphie a été fait par les
chorégraphes de danse donc pas le même
même système existe à la russie
à l'ancienne union soviétique l'a dit
le cirque a un lien très étroite avec la
danse a normalement six heures par jour
tous les jours ils ont quand même la wii
il ya deux trois numéros qui est très
présente et c'était vraiment nouvelles
créations que en europe dans toute
l'europe
c'est la première fois qu'il ya des
numéros traditionnels mais
impressionnant comme les chaises
pyramide de chaises les vélos des
cerceaux
et il ya un numéro qui est très
traditionnel la banque parle en
équilibre des vents sur la tête
c'est un numéro très ancien mais on n'a
pas présenté on n'a pas joué en europe
depuis à mon avis 20 ans
s'ils devaient avoir un c'est une numéro
qui a été créée le mois dernier il ya
deux artistes qui vont fait déséquilibre
au dessus des 2 pâton souple à y mettre
donc ça c'est vraiment ça demande un
entraînement des artistes très très
solide
c'est à dire là le metteur en scène m'a
dit c'est vraiment on peut trouver un
artiste parmi des centaines
en europe nous avons
trentaine de dates en france et puis
bien sûr la saison prochaine en
allemagne en autriche
là j'ai une autre troupe qui tourne en
autriche en allemagne l'année prochaine
cette troupe va prendre le rôle de
l'autre pour pour notre tournée l'année
prochaine il y aura une nouvelle
production que je suis en train
d'organiser le metteur en scène sera à
allemand le compositeur sera canadien il
a travaillé pour plusieurs productions
du cirque du soleil et il a une
compréhension extraordinaire de la
musique chinoise
c'est pour ça que je vais choisi comme
compositeur et le costumier bien de
paris est maintenant un nouveau sujet de
la rédaction ouais je te disais les
soldes hong kong web a maintenant c'est
oui c'est dans le kiosque voilà huawei
un dessin presque une photo sur
porcelaine un sens du détail ine
véronique à bègles vient de décrocher le
diplôme de meilleur ouvrier de france
ce qui va changer c'est humain dit j'ai
plus loin de faire d'erreur modeste vire
au niqab est grand elle a démarré la
peinture sur porcelaine un peu par
hasard dit elle
d'abord diplômé d'un bac arts déco la
versailles s est orientée vers un tout
autre métier
éducatrice de jeunes enfants sans perdre
de vue sa première passion et ce qu'il
avait séduit dès le départ
le côté de décors d'objets donner une
âme un objet il y avait aussi la partie
un peu technique a dépassé
c'est une des plus grandes difficultés
au démarrage
parce que quand on prépare mal sa
peinture ça peut les cahiers alors ça
rend pas ce qu'on veut les couleurs qui
se mangent les autres quand on travaille
l'ofrou
les métaux précieux
c'est une chose avec des cuissons
différentes enfin il ya vraiment une
somme de connaissances à avoir
de loisirs véronique on a fait un métier
un métier très prenant je ne compte pas
mes heures la pièce de concours à clefs
la base j'ai mis plus de 250 heures sans
compter tout le travail d' approche en
fait savoir ce que j'allais faire
j'ai passé deux mois dessus en avant de
lancer sur la pièce m pour remporter le
concours de meilleur ouvrier de france
qui se déroule tous les quatre ans et
véronique à bègles a travaillé sur ce
vase et cette assiette un travail alors
à la frise avec des personnages et des
paysages un savoir faire complet je suis
contente que ça me permet de me dire où
je soutiens mon niveau
encore quelques dates à retenir avant
d'essayer votre nouvelle paire de
santiags le p tit look en moustache
poésie club tentera de sauver le monde
le 24 novembre à la ferme du mousseau à
elancourt tandis que l'excellente auteur
et metteur en scène est la grana
présentera sa pièce misérable libre
cours du 21 au 24 novembre à la ferme de
bel ébat pas guyancourt
le 23 novembre ce sont les sur terre
tellini drôle chanteuse et danseuse qui
donneront de la voix au scarabée à la
verrière et les 24 et 25 novembre vous
pourrez découvrir les aventures de
pinocchio dans une version scénique et
jazz avec les artistes du créa au
théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines le
28 novembre enfin vous pourrez voir on
ne paie pas on ne paie pas la célèbre
pièce de dario fo mise en scène ici par
christophe rouxel à la ferme de bel ébat
à guyancourt des dates que vous pouvez
retrouver ainsi que l'ensemble de la
programmation culturelle des salles
saint-quentinoise dans le kiosque sur
internet aux adresses qui s'affiche et
tous les mardis des places de spectacle
à gagner cette semaine 10 places pour le
concert d'agnès bihl et de l'itie râle
au scarabée
bah